hi I'm Eric Foss in spider-man far from
home ended with a post-credits scene
that might have cracked the MCU wide
open its spoiler warning for far from
home though I think you have had a good
amount of time to go see it still just
want to cover my bases spoilers ahead
Nick Fury and Maria hill have been
revealed to have been scroll
shapeshifters Talos his wife Sauron
returning from Captain Marvel still
living in the present day of the MCU on
earth apparently coordinating with Nick
Fury and apparently not all worried
about other drivers looking over to see
a couple green faces beside them at a
red light it is suggested that fury in
hill worthy Scrolls only for the events
of far from home with Talos reporting to
fury that he followed through on the
order to delivered the late Tony Stark
sunglasses to Peter suggesting that the
squirrel switch happened after Starks
death and Avengers endgame but when we
see the real Nick Fury on the scroll
spaceship where the hell is the real
Maria hill it's kind of like a magic
trick that's only half complete what the
hell's the other rabbit if you have been
following me you know that I have been
obsessed with an investigation for the
missing scroll run away from Captain
Marvel speculated that he or she could
have been hiding among us in plain sight
as a character that we have known for
years I've been mocked laughed away for
suggesting that we may one day see Nick
Fury's shiny bald head turned green but
now vindication shooting webs everywhere
and the fact that the real Maria Hill is
m.i.a has me wondering how much do we
really know about agent hill is there
even a Maria Hill could the Murray Hill
that we thought we knew had been a
squirrel shapeshifter for a lot longer
in the missing greenie I had been
seeking has been at fury side the whole
time say with me the whole time we will
investigate in this episode of
so Maria Hill is a relatively newer
character from the Marvel Comics first
appearing as soon as 2005 she is a
shield operative with no known
superpowers and no well-documented
history the scroll reveal would messily
overturn in other words she's a perfect
candidate to have been an alien
shapeshifter in disguise Hills MCU
history establishes a very vague
backstory as a SHIELD agent in Southeast
Asia with her quickly rising through the
ranks to become Nick Fury's Deputy
Director at 30 years old which you know
isn't out of the realm of possibility
but you know fury was over 60 when he
was director and he had spent decades as
a spy and low-level SHIELD agent doing
grunt work during the Captain Marvel
incident really earning his stripes
so he'll by comparison must have been on
a lightning-quick fast track blowing
right past agent Phil Coulson who
definitely earned his stripes slain a
super heroic role during that Captain
Marvel incident really Hill has kind of
appeared out of nowhere in the MCU
it was Natasha Romanov who was the
associate of Nick Fury in Iron Man 2 and
then he'll just randomly shows up in the
first Avengers accompany in fury into
the project Pegasus lab when the
tesseract was going haywire it's
interesting that these three characters
Nick Fury Phil Coulson and Maria Hill
are meeting back of a tesseract because
we did learn and Captain Marvel that the
tesseract was previously in scrol hands
remember as Marvel was using it to try
to power a Lightspeed engine for their
vessel to find a new homeworld after the
events of Captain Marvel it appeared
that fury kept the tesseract a secret
with goofs having swallowed it talking
it back up on his desk
years later research on the tesseract
resumed under project Pegasus and you
know Maria hill security clearances
deputy director probably would have
clued her in on the tesseract what they
were doing with it but just given how
important the tesseract was to the
scrolls and Captain Marvel the missing
scroll from Captain Marvel would
probably want to remain in close
proximity to it over the years and at
the scene at the beginning of Avengers
hill challenged fury about the
collateral danger of the tesseract I
need you to make sure the phase 2
prototypes is shipped out
that really a priority right now until
such time as the world ends we will act
as though it intention to spin on oh
look at that stink I remember the
scrolls are refugees their homeworld was
ravaged by the Cree forcing them to seek
a new home a scroll would totally know
how horribly real the prospect of the
world ending really is now Hills
defiance of fury also comes from the
decision to use the test track to power
his Phase two weaponry like the scroll
enemy the Cree humans are now using the
cosmic power of the tesseract for war
whereas the scroll wanted it for
peaceful purposes now when I made my
scroll case for Nick Fury one event that
I brought up with Nick Fury's insane
death faked out in Captain America the
Winter Soldier basically Nick Fury was
shot through the freaking chest right in
front of cap and then cap Natasha and
Maria Hill watched as he supposedly
flatlined on the operating table but
later fury was revealed to have been
alive thanks to some brilliant acting by
fury and he'll and dr. Joe Russo acting
that was good enough to trick expert
interrogator and super spy Black Widow
and Captain America so yeah if Maria
hill is capable of keeping a lid on that
conspiracy who knows what else she could
be hiding maybe she even used her scroll
shape-shifting powers to shape-shift her
face back into a grim expression when
fury shat himself to stay in character
another piece of evidence against fury
was the clue that we learned in Captain
Marvel about which name he goes by
everybody calls me fury not Nicholas not
Joseph not Nick later this is a red flag
that fury uses to deduce that his boss
is actually a scroll excellent work
Nicholas so isn't it interesting that
fury doesn't all bet his one I win years
later Maria hill doesn't stick to that
just fury rule multiple bogies makanda
thing energy signatures New York
ten times bigger no client will meet a
me
three Mick's not only that but
rewatching that infinity war
post-credits scene doesn't it sound like
Maria Hill has a bit of a accent on that
first line notes of a bogey so that will
calm down you know what really makes
that odd is that and British slang bogey
means booger
now tell us his wife Sauron doesn't have
a British accent at least in Captain
Marvel but let's assume that the
identity of Maria hill in the MCU at
least was an identity fabricated by that
one missing scroll missus girl number
four from Captain Marvel that squirrel
could have an accent over the years
Yuri could have hidden he'll scroll in
the ranks of shield fast-tracking he'll
scroll up through the ranks to become
his right hand scroll keeping an eye on
the tesseract and keep an eye on him
during the takeover his shield by Hydra
and Winter Soldier Fury would trust one
of the scrolls over Phil Coulson because
Coulson wasn't there for that Captain
Marvel tesseract mission the scrolls
were pivotal to the moment fury became
the fury we know and fury could be
certain that the scroll as an
extraterrestrial would have nothing to
do with Hydra just an alien buddy
removed from all the earth drama leader
in spider-man far from home we learned
that fury in that movie was tail loose
in disguise with the real fury on a
scroll spaceship but we don't see Maria
hill on that ship why not
perhaps the identity of Maria hill could
be one that the scrolls use as a posting
on earth kind of like the santa claus
you see in the mall it's not the real
guy he's up in the North Pole of course
but the Santa who's LAPI sit on could be
any number of alien shapeshifters
rotating in and out similarly when fury
left to go to space and he had Talos
replaced him on earth maybe at that
point
mrs. scroll number four the one from
Captain Marvel the one posing as Maria
hill all those ears could have rotated
back to the scroll ship with fury
rejoining the other Scrolls while the
scrolls Sauron at Alice's wife rotated
down to earth with her husband so that
they could be on deployment together
look at the end of the day folks we just
witnessed Maria hill shape-shift into a
lizard person
and unlike Nick Fury we did not see a
second real Maria hill to reassure us
that a normal human version of her
exists and unlike Nick Fury we don't
have a clear picture of her history
before randomly showing up to this party
where everyone else has known each other
for at least a couple of years and if
Marvel Studios plans a Secret Invasion
movie revealing Maria
to be an alien shapeshifter the entire
time would be a pretty mind-blowing but
fairly understandable twist to swallow
so if we were to apply a squirrel score
to Maria Hill on a scale ranging from
scroll safe scrunge certain scroll
suspicious scroll Sidious and scrum
firmed I'm gonna give him Uriel a Skrull
score of scroll Sidious I was thinking
specious but you know we freaking saw
her shape-shift which should be scrum
firmed but based on the reasonable doubt
over how long she could have been a
scroll I'm just gonna split the
difference but I would say she would tie
with Nick Fury at the highest reading
and going backwards I would say Carol
Danvers probably at scrunt certain Tony
Stark probably scroll safe based on the
heat I got in the comments but you never
can tell so whom do you think I should
investigate next in our scroll search
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow me on instagram and twitter
at EA boss and subscribe to new
rockstars to break down some theories of
everything marble thank you for joining
me and no I will not stop jamming the
awful to pronounce word scroll into
words to make up new words as Thor said
all words are made up oh my god he is
scroll Odin scroll to the archives
[Music]